there's no alternative for a nation of
people that wants a future there's no
alternative to having children
and the assumption that foreign adults
can replace the children raised in
English households
it's an absurd assumption I'm not saying
that the economic measure doesn't have
some kind of value and truth to it the
problem is as is often the case with
liberalism it's this little partial
truth the broader truth is that a
Britain that is not having children has
no future if you you want to have a
future you can't avoid the basic
responsibility of human beings to any
society that they love which is to bring
children into that society and to raise
them with its value and worldview